ok hu
attendez
avez-vous bien porté attention au qe2
selon je leur fais
maintenant qu'avez vous pensé de moi
quel a été votre opinion lorsque je suis
entré dans la pièce le clic les cliques
de mes souliers le mouvement mes bras ma
simple démarche
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé je vous
pose cette question parce que je me
retrouve un peu perdu depuis un certain
temps je suis perdue par rapport à la
société dans laquelle je vis qui devenu
l'équivalent d'une parade de mode où
l'apparence des foi de tout je
m'explique nos biens matériels ils chose
qu'on voit de loin sont maintenant les
éléments qui nous dit finesse si l'on
dit que lorsque je vois quelqu'un je
capable de me dire ok non je m'entendrai
pas avec cette personne ne puis après je
me dis mais dans quel monde on est
rendus en base vraiment nos décisions
sur des futilités comme celle ci mais où
est rendu le contenu
les idées les connaissances les émotions
qui ne constitue majoritairement en tant
que personne à part entière sont
maintenant secondaire je prends
l'exemple de catherine dorion député
taschereau et femmes qui m'inspire
énormément
eh bien madame de riom qui a abordé le
sujet de la culture en chambre suite à
son élection
destitué avec la limite du code
vestimentaire de l'assemblée nationale
au final elle se retrouve avec trois
fois plus d'articles sur le tee shirt
qui a porté qui est sûr le message qu'il
essayait de passer non il pense dans le
vraiment est ce que c'est vraiment les
journaux ou plutôt elle qui ont conquis
a compris qu'on tire maintenant jouer
avec ce genre de détail pourraient être
connus en parlant de journaux le
traitement de la nouvelle est basé sur
le premier coup d'oeil
lire les grands titres au contraire de
lire la vraie substance nous satisfait
et cela nous amène à affecter nos
capacités intellectuelles
alors que nous nous forgeons unités
basées sur des une simple couverture
vous avez déjà entendu parler du racisme
de l'islamophobie du sexisme tous des
sujets très en vogue dans les nouvelles
qui encore une fois sont directement
reliés à notre part ans vous imaginez
l'envergure de tous les conflits causés
par listant les images projetées à nos
yeux nos plus grands problèmes sont
reliés à l'apparence et cela doit
changer
c'est inné tout le monde a des préjugés
sans avoir de mauvaises intentions
notre éducation nous amène à adopter des
idées pré conceptualiser on se crée une
représentation sociale basée sur des
stéréotypes qui sont entretenus au film
parce qu'on garde la même mentalité on
part une certaine capacité d'analysé en
se basant d'après le premier jugement
qui nous vient en tête mais après avoir
constaté ce problème qu'est ce qu'on
fait on crée un système où chacun du duo
les mêmes savoirs et mes responsabilités
la même apparence
dans le fond on perdrait toute l'essence
de ce que c'est que de faire partie de
la race humaine
on perdrait toute la chance que nous
avons des clips de pouvoir découvrir et
explorer peut-on vraiment se rendre aux
citoyens uniforme
vous connaissez la célèbre allégorie de
la caverne des hommes enchaînés depuis
toujours dans une caverne dos à la
lumière du soleil ne peuvent voir que
l'ombre du mont extérieur ils doivent
s'imaginer c'est monter une image pour
tous ceux dont ils voient la forme sur
le mur mais un jour on coupe leur chaîne
un des hommes décident de quitter et
d'enfin découvrir ce qu'il ya là haut
ils se retrouvent complètement ébloui
n'ayant jamais été exposés à ce genre de
lumière il retrouve ses pairs et raconte
qu'il lui était arrivé
la peur et la méfiance entre en jeu il
celui-ci décide de rester dans la
caverne dans le skull preuve que le
premier décide d'y retourner et
s'adapter ceux-ci l'explication m2
pourquoi ne se rende à ce point pour en
découvrir davantage et pour pouvoir
avoir accès à plus on doit être prêt à
mettre l'effort s'adapter comme l'a fait
l'homme avec la lumière est nécessaire
afin passer au dessus des appliques des
apparences ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'en mini en mettant en prenant un peu
de recul
en sachant que l'on doit déjouer nos
prix conception en mettant un minimum
d'une autre cela va changer
est ce lui et on verra un changement
essentiel en sachant que l'on doit avoir
une meilleure perception l'image par son
importance je vous pose une dernière
question vous voyez vous plutôt un lapin
ou un canard parce qu'au final ne pas se
fier aux apparences nous permettra de
voir un deuxième côté des choses et
d'enfin voir que l'apparence n'est pas
importante nous en wallon la tène